this episode is brought to you by Target
[Music]
you've spent weeks arguing about the
mandalorian you'll spend months arguing
about the rise of Skywalker now watch
the one Star Wars movie capable of
uniting the entire fanbase by agreeing
it's the worst theatrically released
movie in the franchise easily Star Wars
the Clone Wars the movie the show is a
different story
gear up for a movie based on a vague
reference to something Mark Hamill said
in 1977 you fought in the Clone Wars yes
but since the Samurai Jack guy made them
look kick-ass one time
Lucasfilm followed up with a poorly
animated kids movie it was really poorly
animated I best be on my way like so
poorly animated every scene ends with
the same animation of someone crossing
their arms
[Music]
did they forget to render this looks
like an educational storm where spin-off
game designed to teach me how to type
your favorite prequel characters are
back yay like Anakin Skywalker who's
only killed sand people at this point
not younglings so he's good
obi-wan who took all the stiffness out
of his personality and transferred it to
his hair Christopher Lee and Sam Jackson
who didn't get the memo they could skip
this one I need three of his star
cruisers haha a bunch of nameless
clothes thanks for the ride Rex Cody
battle positions donate your clones man
you're just gonna get attached ahsoka
tano a sidekick built out of corporate
memos to make a cool young girl Jedi
who's cool and does cool stuff did you
just call me and baby Yoda
exact opposite stinky Oh stinky your
mistake no one will ever speak up again
begun the clone wars have and boring the
Clone Wars are because this is 90 solid
minutes of droid shooting at clones
clothes shooting at droids and space
wizards flipping around in the middle of
it all helping the clone shoot the
droids more betterer but since we know
the same guys running both armies we
know this is all a big distraction that
means absolutely nothing unless you the
guy who owns the rights of a blaster
sound effect in that case chi-ching am i
right
so strap in for the first Star Wars set
entirely inside an actual star war that
somehow more boring than the holiday
special at least that at wookies
watching VR porn still it does feature
the greatest redemption story in Star
Wars no not that guy Dave Bologna who
somehow shook off this mess and turned
it into multiple compelling seasons of
television turned this brat into one of
the most popular characters in the
fandom and proved that there's room for
more than one Hollywood nerd in a cowboy
hat el Mariachi vs the Mandalorian guys
please give it some thought starring
Darth later
poochy a good movie now that's a thing I
haven't made in a long time Pat me on
the dead eyes mr. and mrs. Sith battle
parts and baby slug doop doop de doop to
do baby slug doop de doop to do baby
slug doop doop it's the new babies look
ps2 Jedi power battles
[Music]
so this is around 20 years before a new
hope and jizz music hasn't changed at
all are these guys playing brand new
cutting edges or does the Mos Eisley
cantina have a retro jizz theme this
holiday the toys of a generation of Star
Wars fans come home explore a whole
galaxy of Star Wars toys available at
Target Marvel DC no one on the Internet
has ever thought of making a video
comparing the relative strengths of
their heroes until now click here for an
all-new episode of power levels and see
if you could handle Superman's pelvic
thrust